TUCKER IS BACK TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHETHER COLLEGE IS REALLY WORTH
IT.
>> IS IF YOU NEEDED MORE PROOF
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION IS THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED AND MOST
PREDATORY RACKET UNDERWAY IN
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW THERE IS
THIS, HARVARD JUST
ANNOUNCED ITS CLASSES WILL
BE ENTIRELY ONLINE THIS FALL BUT
THE SCHOOL ISN’T TAKING A SINGLE
DIME OFF ITS TUITION.
THAT IS STILL $50,000 A YEAR.
OF COURSE IT’S BY DESIGN.
THAT TUITION IS NOT PAYING FOR A
BETTER EDUCATION.
IT’S PAYING FOR BLOATED
ADMINISTRATOR SALARIES AND AN
ARMY OF POINTLESS BUREAUCRATS.
IN FACT, NOT AS POINTLESS.
SOME OF THEM POISONOUS.
RIGHT NOW FOR EXAMPLE, THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
HAS 200 A.D. THOUSAND STUDENTS
ENROLLED.
AT THIS TIME TIM HAD HAS 227,000
EMPLOYEES.
DO THE MATH ON THAT.
ISAAC MOORHOUSE HAS AND HE’S A
CEO OF CRASH .CO, A COMPANY THAT
HELPS PEOPLE WITHOUT DEGREES GET
GOOD PAYING JOBS.
HE ALSO FOUNDED AN ORGANIZATION
IT’S PINK IS $1,000 TO DROP OUT
OF COLLEGE AND ENTERING
APPRENTICESHIPS INSTEAD.
ISAAC, WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
ON ALWAYS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS A MOMENT
FOR YOU BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE,
CORRECT ME IF I’M WRONG, ARE
STARTING TO REALIZE THAT COLLEGE
IS A SCAM.
>> YEAH, IT’S A HUGE MOMENT.
COLLEGE HAS BASICALLY BEEN
SCAMMING YOUNG PEOPLE FOR A LONG
TIME AND IT’S BEEN ABLE TO GET
AWAY WITH IT BECAUSE THEY ARE
HEAVILY SUBSIDIZED THROUGH TAX
DOLLARS, PROTECTED FROM
COMPETITION, ESSENTIALLY
MONOPOLIES, AND THERE HAS BEEN A
RELIGIOUS SUPERSTITION THAT YOU
HAVE TO GET THAT DEGREE.
YOU HAVE TO GET THE BULLET POINT
ON YOUR RESUME AND I THINK MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE SEE THAT THAT’S
NOT TRUE.
WHAT YOU JUST SAID, IF YOU’RE
PAYING $50,000 TO GO TO CLASSES
ON ZOOM, YOU KNOW, THE ARGUMENT
THAT YOU’RE GETTING SOME
INTANGIBLE BENEFITS, LIKE THE
ONLY INTANGIBLES ARE THE PENSION
THE ADMINISTRATORS ARE GETTING.
THAT’S WHAT IT’S FUNDING.
MORE PEOPLE ARE AWAKE TO THIS
WHICH I THINK IS A GREAT THING.
IT’S BEEN A HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO SEE WHAT REALLY
MATTERS ON THE JOB MARKET.
>> Tucker: SO I MEAN, THIS
ISN’T JUST A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE ETHICS OF WHETHER OR NOT TO
GO TO COLLEGE BECAUSE I THINK
THERE ARE BIG ETHICAL
IMPLICATIONS PUT THE MONEY
DOESN’T EVEN MAKE SENSE.
GIVE US AN IDEA, BECAUSE MOST
PARENTS ARE AFRAID NOT TO SEND
THEIR KIDS TO COLLEGE.
GIVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT YOUR
OPTIONS ARE IF YOU DON’T WANT TO
SEND THEIR KIDS, WHAT THEIR
OPTIONS ARE.
>> IT’S AMAZING HOW FEW PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT WHAT IT IS THEY
ACTUALLY NEED TO WIN A JOB.
I WILL TELL YOU NOW, HEY, LOOK,
I BOUGHT A DEGREE AND LISTED IT
ON MY RESUME.
YOU CAN BRING YOUR RESUME.
I’M TELLING YOU, THAT’S NOT HOW
YOU GET A JOB ANYMORE.
YOU HAVE TO GAIN SOME REAL
SKILLS AND THEN PITCH COMPANIES
ON THE VALUE YOU CAN CREATE FOR
THEM.
THAT’S WHAT WE HELP ABLE TO ADD
CRASHES TO CREATE SOMETHING THAT
SHOWCASES THEIR SKILLS IN A
TANGIBLE WAY INSTEAD OF JUST
SAYING HERE, THIS INSTITUTION
SET I’M OKAY.
I PASSED.
AT SOME OF YOU CAN GET THOSE
SKILLS, LIKE I’M TELLING YOU
RIGHT NOW, YOU CAN DO THIS IN
MONTHS OR A YEAR OR TWO.
A LOT OF PROGRAMS, YOU DON’T PAY
TUITION UNLESS YOU GET A JOB.
THERE’S A LOT OF CREDIBILITY.
BOOT CAMP SAID, YOU CAN GO IN
AND PRACTICE OR INTERN AND GET
THE EXPERIENCE FIRST BEFORE YOU
SINK A BUNCH OF MONEY THAT
YOU’RE NEVER GOING TO GET BACK.
THEY COLLEGE ISN’T GOING TO GIVE
YOU A REFUND IF THEY IF YOU DON’
HIRED.
THEY’RE GOING TO BE LAUGHING TO
THE BANK.
THERE’S OPPORTUNITY OUT THERE TO
DISCOVER THE KIND OF THING
YOU’RE INTERESTED IN AND IN
BUILDINGS AROUND THOSE, ACTUALLY
DO SOMETHING TANGIBLE INSTEAD OF
JUST FOLLOWING THE RULES AND
SAYING HEY, I GOT THIS
CREDENTIAL.
>> Tucker: SO THERE IS NOT A
CORRELATION BETWEEN GETTING A
CREDENTIAL IN YOUR
EFFECTIVENESS.
HOW DOES A PARENT OR CHILD THINK
ABOUT WHAT TO DO NEXT GET
INVOLVED WITH CRASH?
>> CRASHES REALLY DESIGNED FOR
IF YOU ARE ON THE JOB MARKET NOW
AND THAT COULD BE AN
INTERNSHIP.
HE COULD BE A FIRST JOB.
IT’S REALLY A WAY TO FIND HOW TO
SHOWCASE YOUR SKILLS AND NOT
HAVE TO RELY ON HAVING FANCY
CREDENTIALS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT AND PUT TOGETHER A
COMPELLING PITCH TO COMPANIES
AND WE WALK YOU THROUGH THAT AND
IF YOU’RE READY FOR IT, IF
YOU’RE READY FOR THE JOB MARKET,
CHECK OUT CRASH .CO.
IF YOU’RE NOT, I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO LOOK INTO BOOT CAMPS.
CODING.
PRAXIS IS A BOOT CAMP FOR
NONCODERS.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO DROP OUT OF
COLLEGE, THEY ARE OFFERING TO
PAY YOU A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT’S REALLY RIGOROUS TRAINING
AND SKILLS IN DEMAND AND
FAST-GROWING COMPANIES TODAY SO
THOSE ARE JUST A COUPLE PLACES
TO START BUT THERE’S MORE
OPPORTUNITY THAN THERE’S EVER
BEEN TO LEARN RELEVANT SKILLS.
I’M TELLING YOU, NONE OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY IS IN COLLEGE
CLASSROOMS RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: WE ARE ALL ON
LEARNING THE G.I. BILL 75 YEARS